great work thumbs up the data has landed
safely on our phones but I was thinking
about it and actually instead of
hard-coding our postcode in we'd really
like our sunshine app user to be able to
change their location in the settings so
let's make the fetchweathertask more
flexible by having it take as input a
postal code parameter while we're doing
that we should also take this
opportunity to do a little bit of
refactoring instead of concatenating the
strings for the server query URL we
should use a URI builder class to build
up the URL we can declare a base URL and
then append each pair of query pram and
pram
to it this includes params for postcode
JSON format metric units and de count
this will make it easier in the future
if we ever have to make these options
configurable by the user if you want to
verify that the URL is built up properly
after you do these tasks you can use for
both logging to print it out